[Applause]
[Music]
you mermaids and if you take off your cap
and its time on you must I climb
easiest the you ready computer engine
delaware scalable and high performance
bridge maybe tension in google
cities centers nice to it maybe
can yoni from peter pan in  the podcast you
might be soul and much you want at
juice general purpose machines becomes
apel databases and web servers
to get a response but might track in
with military bases
on a real time handling corner of your eye your
optima is machines but he example
group think when they model a  gaming
at argu your computers absolutely beautiful
intense workloads my guitar and i hear
with the grange you can hivemind 3 between
guest with ali booming so you choose
rationally the viewing maintenance i do
is right size recommendations louisa with
young maybe time depending on your
usage you pay  what you use and the [ __ ]
is that dave wings with your pranks
a youtube account
chopard clients balbian di  e war has
got some instances
you of patience and fall marry
pencil you could you and you to my
bridges and to google cloud bran
databases to financial modeling
for centuries windows black lacquer
stand you I think my measurement you
hit the cloud quickly to i
of course and cue en ze
for more info check out loud it does
it on stage by cute